operation high jump commenced in august
1946. it was the largest most heavily
armed naval task force ever sent to
antarctica leading the mission was
admiral richard e byrd one of the most
famous naval officers in history the
official purpose for the expedition was
scientific research and military
training but that was just a cover story
operation high jump had other goals one
was to extend american sovereignty over
antarctica something that was denied
many times by the us government another
was to locate and destroy a secret nazi
base
and capture the nazi's new secret weapon
the flying saucer
ufos were seen all over the area
suspected to be nazi test flights
admiral byrd was sent to find out did
they find flying sources oh they found a
lot more than that
[Music]
in december 1938 aware that he was on
the brink of war hitler dedicated
considerable resources to searching for
mysterious ancient artifacts said to
have incredible power
one of these expeditions launched on
december 17
1938 the ss schwabenland was sent on a
secret mission to antarctica on board
were scientists and engineers but also
members of the thule society a german
occultist group the thule society
believed that a highly advanced race of
human-like beings called aryans existed
somewhere deep inside the earth and the
entrance to their world was at the south
pole the classified mission of the ss
schwabenland was to find a location for
a secret underground base and make
contact with the aryans living in the
hollow earth and once contact was made
negotiate for access to their technology
the ship reached the antarctic coast a
month later for the next three weeks
they mapped hundreds of thousands of
square miles of the continent about 150
miles inland aerial reconnaissance found
what is described as an arctic oasis an
area about 300 square miles that was
free of ice filled with warm water and
even contained plant life and the ocean
beneath the oasis was a geothermal vent
that kept the area relatively warm this
was the ideal place for a base
especially for u-boats this is where the
nazis would establish the infamous
underground facility known as base 211.
over the course of world war ii base 211
became a massive complex as large as a
small city initially it was designed as
an offensive structure where u-boats and
missiles could be deployed but as the
tide of war turned against the axis
powers it became clear that the base
would be an ideal way to escape in the
final months of the war huge amounts of
equipment supplies and personnel were
transported to antarctica at the same
time thousands of nazis escaped justice
and were smuggled to south america with
most of them hiding in argentina one of
the infamous german officers to
disappear was hans kamler cameron was in
charge of hitler's secret weapons
program kamler's engineers had created a
prototype long distance supply plane
with a range of over 4 000 miles called
the ju390 only two of these were made
one of them belonged to kamler and as of
april 1945 neither kamlar nor his plane
have ever been found and just a few
months later thousands of ufo sightings
were reported all over south america the
american government feared that kamlar
and his scientists had escaped to
antarctica where they were continuing
their work operating out of a secret
military base hidden deep underground
but these were just rumors there was
only one way to find out
go to antarctica
[Music]
okay before we talk about what admiral
byrd saw in antarctica come on just get
to the weird stuff i will but it's
important that you understand what kind
of man richard bird was he was not some
pseudo-science conspiracy theorist kook
he was a legitimate badass here are the
bullet points richard byrd reached the
rank of rear admiral by the age of 41
the youngest admiral in navy history now
that by itself is impressive but how
about this he was a recipient of the
medal of honor the navy cross the flying
cross and the silver life-saving medal
in all he received 22 citations and
commendations including nine for bravery
and two for extraordinary heroism he was
to this day one of the most highly
decorated officers in the history of the
navy now his resume goes on but i think
you get the point if admiral byrd says
he wants to be the first man to fly over
the north pole he does it and if the
united states sends a major expedition
to the south pole to conduct a
top-secret mission well there's no more
qualified person on the face of the
earth to lead it than admiral richard e
byrd operation high jump commenced in
august 1946. the official purpose of the
mission was to train personnel and test
equipment in cold temperatures to
explore arctic geology study the weather
and develop techniques for establishing
air bases in frigid climates admiral
byrd led a navy task force of almost 5
000 men aboard 13 ships including a
brand new state-of-the-art aircraft
carrier loaded with dozens of planes
bombers and helicopters this task force
was armed to the teeth there were two
destroyers tankers supply ships
icebreakers two heavily armed seaplanes
and an attack submarine all fully
stocked with the best weapons in the
entire
navy that's a lot of firepower for
training exercises and studying the
weather right
that mission was the cover story no
personnel training or equipment testing
ever took place no practice maneuvers no
military exercises no scientific study
of any kind was ever done according to
eyewitness testimony declassified
records and byrd's own journal operation
high jump had other purposes one goal
was to extend american sovereignty over
the antarctic continent something that
was denied many times publicly by the us
government naturally the other goal was
to locate and destroy the secret nazi
military complex known as base 211 and
to capture any flying saucers they could
the armada arrived on january 15th and
immediately started building a base
called little america but then the
operation high jump story takes a turn
originally meant to be a six to eight
month mission after just 40 days the
base is evacuated and the task force
withdraws
this massive expensive and important
mission is suddenly terminated so
what happened and this is where admiral
byrd a legend in his own time becomes a
legend for all time
the navy task force retreated to chile
and as soon as they made port rumors
spread about strange findings and
disasters that forced the mission to be
cut short admiral byrd himself spoke to
the media and rather than deny the
stories he expressed deep concern about
the real possibilities of devastating
aerial attacks on the us and this
doesn't sound like a guy on a scientific
mission it sure doesn't
bird warned that it was imperative for
the united states to take immediate
defensive measures against hostile
forces in the arctic and antarctic the
admiral went on to say that he wasn't
trying to alarm anyone
but the cruel reality is that in case of
a new war the united states could be
attacked by flying objects that had the
ability to move from pole to pole at
incredible speeds admiral byrd
reiterated this in a few different
statements he warned that there was a
new enemy that could attack any country
at any time anywhere no matter the
distance
when admiral byrd got back to washington
he was immediately debriefed and though
he had just spent two weeks making
statements in the press after a lengthy
interrogation admiral byrd never uttered
another word about operation high jump
the mission was immediately classified
top secret and any sailor who spoke
about the mission would be arrested and
imprisoned the navy then published a
brief summary of the mission's
achievements and admitted some sailors
were killed but they didn't say how many
and officially all the deaths were
accidents and the bodies were buried
there not brought home during one of his
flights admiral byrd was missing for
three hours in an episode of lost time
but that was officially blamed on radio
failure the official reason for
terminating the mission early was poor
weather conditions and that was that
however you know how admiral byrd was
missing for three hours and experienced
lost time
well bird was meticulous at documenting
everything but when he returned to the
states his journals were confiscated and
classified
but the government didn't get everything
he had a secret diary that he gave to
his son right before he died and if any
of what he claims to have seen is true
well it changes everything
[Music]
according to admiral byrd's diary he
fuels up for a flight early in the
morning the weather is clear and
mechanically the plane checks out at 8
15 at an altitude of 2 300 feet he
checks in 0 8 15 hours radio check with
base camp situation
at 10 after 9 he notices a color pattern
in the snow nothing extreme but he
circles the area to get a closer look he
makes visual contact with camp and
radios in his findings then his
instruments start to act strange he
writes that both his compasses are
gyrating so much that he can't even use
them so he uses the sun to navigate and
maintains a visual of camp he reports
that his controls are feeling sluggish
he's concerned about the wings icing up
there's a little ice but no indication
of a problem so he continues flying
toward what he perceives as a mountain
range 0-9 49 hours 29 minutes elapsed
flight time from the first sighting of
the mountains it is no illusion they are
mountains and consisting of a small
range that i have never seen before he
crosses the mountain range and descends
toward what he describes as a green
valley with a small river running
through it there should be no green
valley below something is definitely
wrong and abnormal here we should be
over ice and snow to the port side are
great forests growing on the mountain
slopes our navigation instruments are
still spinning the gyroscope is
oscillating back and forth he drops down
a bit and circles back for a closer look
he reports the green as being moss or
tight grass the light seems different
here he can see the ground easily but he
can no longer see the sun now this
starts to worry him because he's using
the sun to navigate but he gets
distracted by something he didn't expect
on the green valley below
a large animal is grazing it appears to
be an elephant no it looks more like a
mammoth this is incredible yet there it
is decrease altitude to 1000 feet and
take binoculars to better examine the
animal it is confirmed it is definitely
a mammoth like animal report this to
base camp admiral byrd flies over green
pastures that stretch for miles and he's
so amazed by what he's seeing it takes
him almost 30 minutes to realize
it's not cold anymore
frost on his forward window is gone same
with the bits of ice that were on the
wings he removes his gloves the window
of the canopy is warm to the touch he
records an external air temperature of
74 degrees fahrenheit
his instruments are now back online but
his radio is out and remember in the
official report admiral byrd was out of
radio contact for three hours so he
flies for another hour over what looks
to be a countryside or a pasture on the
horizon
he sees the impossible a large shining
city
the plane shutters admiral byrd grabs
the controls but they're not responding
he notices the plane feels light and
buoyant
then on both sides of the plane
strange aircraft are rapidly closing in
their discs shaped and seem to be
radiating light and somehow they're
running completely silent now thinking
this is now a really good time to head
back admiral byrd tries the controls
again no luck the plane's engine
suddenly cuts out but somehow continues
flying controlled by some unseen force
the craft are right up alongside his
plane now close enough that admiral byrd
can see markings in that instant his
wonder turns to terror the markings are
swastikas
[Music]
according to documents leaked in 1991
things back at camp little america take
a strange turn just two days after
arriving bright lights were seen on the
horizon the sailors thought it was
another ship but they were below the
antarctic circle in uncharted waters the
lights then ascended at a 45 degree
angle into the sky very quickly they
tried to make radar contact but were out
of range three hours later five more
lights appeared in the sky and began
flying directly toward the ships
anti-aircraft guns and 20-millimeter
cannons were fired but had no effect a
radio operator stationed on the uss
brownson gave testimony of how strange
crafts suddenly appeared from the ocean
this is corroborated by lieutenant john
sayerson who said objects shot
vertically out of the water at
tremendous speeds one object flew
between the mass of his ship with such
force that the radio antenna oscillated
back and forth from the turbulence an
aircraft from the uss kurutuk took to
the sky but was immediately struck by a
beam of energy and destroyed about 10
miles away the torpedo boat uss maddox
burst into flames and began to sink
according to the report this was the
first attack of several that would occur
over the next few weeks february 26
would be the last engagement with the
unknown craft the navy task force
ordered retreat and left the area a full
six months before their mission was
supposed to end although lieutenant
sayerson couldn't identify the lights he
wondered if they were what he called
german wonder weapons being operated by
survivors of the recently defeated third
reich operating out of a secret base
under antarctica his testimony has
fueled speculation that still exists and
to this day investigators are trying to
determine
what really happened during operation
high jump
[Music]
admiral byrd's radio which hadn't been
working for at least an hour suddenly
comes back to life though the signal was
distorted a voice starts speaking
english with a slightly german accent
welcome admiral to our domain we shall
land you in exactly seven minutes relax
admiral you are in good hands the plane
gently lands itself an admiral bird is
met by several men all tall with blonde
hair
sounds like it bird joins the strangers
on a platform that levitates and rushes
them toward the city at great speed he's
directed to an elevator that takes him
quickly and silently deep underground he
is to have an audience with the master
admiral byrd is led into another room
where an older man is seated at a long
table admiral bird is asked to sit down
the master says his people are called
the ariani and they've been observing
humans for a long time
but only now are they choosing to
interfere the master says that admiral
byrd's race is too immature for atomic
energy and are at risk of destroying
themselves the master says every time
they try to make contact their ships are
fired upon and pursued by fighter planes
so instead they chose admiral byrd to
carry this message because he's a famous
and well-respected figure the master
hopes that the world will believe him
after the meeting the admiral is
escorted back to his plane and after
flying for a few minutes a voice comes
through the radio that control of the
aircraft is now his a voice says alfida
sane and disconnects definitely aryans
when admiral byrd arrives at the
pentagon in march 1947 he is debriefed
and interrogated for hours he relays the
message from the master and advises the
president he's ordered to remain silent
about the operation and indeed admiral
richard e byrd never spoke a word about
this mission again the final entry in
his diary is a number of years later
admiral byrd feels what he calls the
long night coming but doesn't want this
knowledge to die with him just as the
long night of the arctic ends the
brilliant sunshine of truth shall come
again and those who are of darkness
shall fall in its light for i have seen
that land beyond the pole that center of
the great unknown admiral richard e byrd
united states navy 24th of december 1956
an admiral byrd passed away three months
later this secret diary was found by his
son richard byrd jr and subsequently
released as was his father's wish and 18
months after that the antarctic treaty
was signed forbidding anyone from going
to antarctica without special permission
from one of 12 signatory governments and
even with special permission you may
only go in a few small designated areas
antarctica is bigger than europe bigger
than australia bigger than the entire
united states yet all that land is off
limits
why
was there a secret nazi base is there a
civilization living underground the ufos
described by the sailors in 1947 behave
an awful lot like ufos we're seeing
right now since we can't go to their
world they could be trying to come to us
with the same warning they gave admiral
byrd so maybe instead of trying to
destroy these craft and destroy each
other we might want to listen to what
they have to say and who knows the
entire fate of the world may depend on
it
okay talk about a story having it all
ufos nazi bases government cover-ups
even hollow earth and i've done a lot of
research on hollow earth so if you want
to see that video let me know in the
comments anyway i'll tell you right up
front there's a lot of the story that
can be debunked
but not all of it let's start with
admiral byrd's secret diary it's not
real first of all the flight in the
diary takes place in the north pole so
we're already off to a rocky start since
antarctica is as far south as you can
get and some of the log entries are
almost identical to actual published log
entries from the admiral the same types
of instrument failures engine issues
show up in both places for some reason
also whole paragraphs of what the master
said to admiral byrd seem to be
plagiarized from the 1937 film lost
horizon where the main character is
talking to the dalai lama who issues the
same kind of warning in 1964 a book
about the hollow earth was released by
walter siegmeister under the pen name
raymond bernard admiral byrd is
mentioned quite a bit in the book
bernard went on to write lots of books
about ufos and hollow earth and later
when bird's secret diary appeared guess
who wrote the foreword
yep raymond bernard but the dead
giveaway for me the secret diary is full
of exclamation points like lots of them
if you read any of bird's other logs no
matter how excited he gets he doesn't
write like he's posting on reddit he
writes like a gentleman so what about
the nazis here's where it gets tricky
the schwaben land did go to antarctica
in 1938 but its mission was to secure
new ports for whaling to supply germany
with its own whale oil for margarine
a nazi mission to the south pole for a
delicious buttery spread exactly
germany wasn't at war yet but hitler was
planning it a lot of oil and fat based
products were imported hitler wanted to
make sure that these industries could
continue and his army could be fed in
case foreign supplies were cut off the
nazi mission did claim some land for
germany and it's widely thought that
they did look for a location for a base
and maybe even tried to build one but no
evidence of a base has been found
however nazi artifacts have been found
in the arctic in the north which could
be why this story continues to circulate
but so far nothing in the south could be
underground
it could be i'm not saying nothing's
there i'm just saying we haven't found
it yet but they found it and aren't
telling anybody well that's always a
possibility the us government did lie
about the real purpose of operation high
jump and it's true admiral byrd never
spoke about it publicly except for those
cryptic comments in the chilean
newspaper el mercurio el mercurio is a
real paper and admiral byrd did give
them an interview obviously the article
was released in spanish but when it was
translated back to english his words
were twisted around to make the story
sound more dramatic never let the facts
get in the way of a good story right
bird never said there are ships that can
fly pole to pole at tremendous speeds he
said the united states could be attacked
by planes coming from the poles and it
should be ready for that an operation
high jump had a press contingent about a
dozen reporters giving daily reports
there really wasn't much going on so
rather than send back a three-word story
lots of ice the reporters added their
own flair for example bird did find a
small lake that had uniquely warm
temperatures with algae growing in it
but it was reported as a land of blue
and green lakes and brown hills in an
otherwise limitless expanse of ice
right
in 1991 after the collapse of the soviet
union millions of secret documents were
released and one of those written in
1947 was a description of operation high
jump and in 2006 a russian documentary
was released based on that secret
intelligence report the soviets did
believe that operation high jump was a
mission to find and destroy a nazi base
and look with all that firepower i don't
think that's a stretch the reports of
the battle with ufos comes from the
soviet documents but it's iffy on the
facts and they got some of the names of
the ships wrong but they did get some
right and the us military has a history
of changing a ship's name and rewriting
the ship's story if it serves navy
policy
always the soviet report said that ufos
weren't trying to destroy the american
ships which they easily could have done
they just wanted the ships to turn back
the mission was cut way short the
official reason for that is weather but
that's a lot of resources wasted because
of weather were there really ufos
protecting something down there or is
this disinformation deliberately leaked
to the soviets by u.s intelligence
i don't know
i've debunked as much as i can for you
even though a lot of the story is false
not all of it is and it seems as the
only way we'll get answers is to go to
antarctica but if there's one thing that
every government in the world agrees on
it's that whatever is down there needs
to stay there but i'll leave you with
these final thoughts just a few months
after operation high jump a ufo
allegedly crashed in roswell new mexico
the location of the crash is only a few
miles from the world's first nuclear
explosion and admiral byrd did go
missing for three hours and arrived back
at camp three hours late he was in a
small short-range airplane so
why didn't he run out of fuel
[Music]
thanks so much for hanging out with me
today my name is aj that's hecklefish
this has been the y-files if you had fun
or learned anything do me a favor like
subscribe comment share all that stuff
really helps a small channel the
algorithm is cruel to us but with your
help i think we can defeat it until next
time be safe be kind and know that you
are appreciated
[Music]
you